I do have some mailbag questions let's
pump this thing up let's juice this spot
a little bit oh okay let's juice the pot
do you often break bones because of
carrying the weight of being the best
actor on Sunny
who would win in a fight Poppins are
special agent Jack Bauer cats are gonna
win if you could choose an actor or
actress to guest star on Sunny who would
it be can I bring Betty White back from
the dead because that would be so nice
there's a fan that is asking if there
are any Caitlyn Justice stories
this next question which is just simply
why Rob oh yeah
after all after all that oh sorry that's
not for you it's for breakfast
[Music]
foreign